Bladesmiths,
welcome to the Forge.
Every bladesmith
has a favorite knife.
[all chuckling]
[host] Gentlemen,
I have here a dagger,
a kukri, a karambit,
a coffin-handle Bowie
and a jambiya.
You will need to choose
a blade style
and combine it
with a different knife's handle
in order to create
your own mash-up blade.
Good luck.
Your three hours starts now.
Combining two different blades
into one,
you have
to think about it.
'Cause some of them
may look cool on paper,
but it's not gonna blend well
unless you really look
into the details.
I'm looking at these knives
and in the back of my mind
is Jay Neilson
swinging as hard as he can
on that deer antler.
The blades have to be good
for an antler chop.
It has to be good
for a fish slice.
That's a lot
of different iterations.
I decide I'm gonna go
with the kukri blade
because I think it's the best
design for the challenge.
And I think it will marry up
with that coffin handle.
That's a winner.
We've got a coffin-handle kukri
over here out of Vince as well.
I settle on
the Bowie-knife blade.
It's just
a tried and true blade
and that karambit-style handle.
It's got a good feel to it.
When it's in the hand,
it's got a nice curve to it.
And I'm thinking
that's gonna work for me.
[Vince] I wanna save time.
So I decided
to draw the billet
and forge the knife
simultaneously.
Big Blue is a beast.
I need one of those
in my shop.
Now that they're
into the shaping phase,
Big Blue can quickly
topple your metal.
It can pop it flat.
Ooh.
Big Blue's got a lot of control
and he gets away from me
and he crushes my tip.
At this point, I realize
the power tools allow me
to move metal real quick,
but I'm getting
to the detail work
and at this point
they're dangerous.
I need to start
doing this by hand.
Ihope that crushed tip
is not an issue.
Heat, beat, repeat!
I'm done
pressing that steel down
to a workable size.
So as I'm shaping this knife,
I'm working on the blade first.
But with a Bowie,
a lot of times you're gonna
put a guard on there
and maybe a hidden tang
or maybe a coffin tang.
So I'm keeping
in the back of my head that,
"Hey, this handle's
gonna be different
than what a Bowie calls for."
[host] Casey's Bowie's starting
to also take shape.
[host 2] I'm really liking
the way
the Bowie-style blade
is coming out,
but I'm worried
about that karambit handle,
especially
for the antler chop.
So I'm trying to put
the bend on this with my hammer
and it's not working
really well.
A kukri without the bend
is not a kukri.
That's the defining factor
of a kukri.
So, I need to figure out
how to put the bend in now.
[Wil] We've got Shawn
on the horn of the anvil,
really trying to knock
that belly,
that inside curve
into
the coffin-handled kukri.
That's the way I shape kukris.
[Shawn] I've seen where
people bang it over the horn
and gravity will naturally
put that bend in,
and it bent down
right like I thought.
I'm done putting the bend
in the kukri
and I'm on to
profiling my handle
to make sure that it looks
like a coffin handle.
Right now Vince's tang section
is really fat.
I chose to leave it thick
because it's always easier
to remove material
than it is to add on.
It's time to go quench.
[Jay] Vincejust quenched
his blade.
Looked like
a good temperature.
The handle
wasn't heated up at all.
I have no cracks, no warp
and I have a hard blade.
I know I'm in great shape.
-We did the same thing, bro.
-Yeah, buddy.
Looks good, man.
My profile's done,
and I know
what a good blade feels like.
So in my hand
I'm swinging it around
to make sure it's not sliding
around the hand,
not wanting
to jump out of my grip.
It's that time
for the heat treat.
It's smart that Casey
didn't harden the whole blade
because in one of those rings,
you forge it in,
-always a lot of clean up.
-Yeah.
I'm hoping that nothing went
catastrophically wrong.
I don't wanna pull out
a banana.
I bring it out and it's just
perfectly straight.
All right. She sounds hard.
It's time to quench, so,
never having quenched W1,
I'm very concerned about
the temperature of the blade.
I just don't know.
Is that too [bleep] hot?
-[sizzles]
-Oh!
It's hotter than snot.
That is no bueno.
I have a soft spot in
the recurve of my blade.
I bite the bullet
and do it again.
Hopefully
it's going to harden.
[Wil] Three, two, one!
Bladesmiths,
shut down your machines!
Drop your tools!
This first round of mash-up
competition is over!
Whoo!
Bladesmiths, I know you had fun
making these
mix-and-match weapons.
But I know
this is your favorite part,
the strength test.
We're not only gonna test
the overall construction,
but how well you designed
your mash-up weapons
for these tests.
What I'm gonna do is take
each of your
mix-and-match weapons here
and smash them repeatedly and
violently into these antlers.
Now, keep in mind,
I'm not concerned about what
your blades do to the antler.
I wanna see what the antlers
do to your blades.
Shawn, you're up first.
[chuckles] Let's do it.
[tense music playing]
[grunting]
-[men gasping]
-Watch out!
[metal clanks on the floor]
[tense music playing]
[sighs] Damn.
The warp's gone.
The warp is gone.
Your edge itself held up well.
Just a small bit
of shine to it.
And it bit in nicely,
but you've got a pretty large
grain structure here.
It was a little too high
a temperature when you quenched
and if you look
at the bottom here,
there's like a little bit
of a brownish discoloration.
Means there was
a stress fracture in there.
It could have been
too small to see it,
but, obviously, it was there.
Right.
[Wil] Well, Shawn,
unfortunately,
Jay has a way with blades.
[chuckles] Yeah.
Your blade has failed after
five strikes on the antler.
It doesn't mean
that you're out,
because each of you
have to survive five strikes
in order to move forward
in this competition.
Alright, Jay.
Casey, after seeing
what happened to Shawn's blade,
-how're you feeling?
-Give it hell.
-[tense music playing]
-[grunting]
[grunting continues]
[grunts]
[Wil] Casey, looks like
your karambit-Bowie mash-up
survived.
Great construction.
Shawn, your fate
lies in the hands
of how strong
Vince's blade is.
Jay?
[Vince] All I need is
for my blade to survive
five hits on that antler.
My heart has never been
beating as hard
as it is right now.
-[tense music playing]
-[thumps]
[grunting]
[exhales sharply]
Well, Vince, five successful
strikes on the antler
pushes you forward
in this competition
and unfortunately,
pushes you
out of the competition, Shawn.
Please exit the Forge.
My goal coming here, A: don't
blow the place up... check.
And B: don't be the first guy
that gets sent home.
So, I did
what I came here to do.
Anything else was gonna be
icing on the cake for me.
You have to do something
you love and I still love it.
I'm gonna go home
and make more blades
soon as I get there.